Nên quan đến vụ xe autoflu thương đâm vào đưa xe autodow kéo, người hộ quả đặc biệt nghiêm trọng, khiến bác người từ vòng,
sẽ ra vào không dường mấy mũn phút hùng qua mấy tám tháng 12 năm, ngày khu trăm 20 năm.
Tại khu vực đường giữ vở trạm dừng gỵ cao tốc thình vô chiming, lòng thình dầu dây.
Cơ quan kể rất đưa trạm quan tình đồng nai đang tính thành sắp mình làm só miên nhân,
được hiện và chế nghiệm của các tập thị và cã nhân theo phía định của pháp lật.
Cục kể rất sợ thông đả sắp miên làm só, sẽ kêu thương bị số 5 mốt bê, 5 mốt hai ba mà,
tôi không tìm chế nghiệm hiểu hạn dị vụ thương hại cường phút học, phương nhớ lòng thành phố chiming,
đã được ký hợp đồng cũng có phụ vận chuyển bệnh với bình Việt trở dễ.
Ngay mệt sò tháng 2 năm, ngày khu trăm 20 năm, theo đình gỵ của gia đình bệnh nhân nở tê lợa,
nạn nhân đã từ vòng trong vụ tên á, bố phận điều xe của bình Việt đã có phía điều xe kêu thương đưa bệnh nhân ra phyện và đi cùng gia đình.
Mống người, sẽ đi từ bình Việt trở dễ đình phương á nhân đông, tình ra lai mà không có bác sĩ,
ít ta đi cùng bệnh nhân.
Lại xe kêu thương là ông đến hữu tê, sinh năm 1915, chú phương phủ thọc,
tình phù chi mình đã bật có, đánh yêu tiên và đi đến định điểm trên và sế ra tên ánh ra thông,
bật bật có đánh yêu tiên trong chương hợp này là xa quy định của pháp lật.
Theo quy định của pháp lật, xe ôt tổ khu thương chỉ được xử dụng có,
đánh và được quyền yêu tiên khi tham gia ra thông đường bộ trong các chương hợp.
Chẳng về bệnh đi cấp vữ.
Đi đáng về bệnh cấp vữ.
Chờ thay thuốc, nhân viên i tế, tuốc, chào thiết bị i tế phục vụ cấp vữ tham hoạc,
cấp vữ tên ánh và các yêu cầu các thiết khác của hã động xin môn khá bệnh,
chứ bệnh và phòng trong sế bệnh.
Theo tổ kêu thương chỉ được xử dụng tiên bị pháp tiền hiệu của xe được quyền yêu tiên.
Hí có dây phép xử dụng tiên bị pháp tiền hiệu của xe được quyền yêu tiên còn được lúc bạc hi đang thực hiện những vụ.
Theo kêu định của pháp luật về ra thông đường bộ.
Cục kẻ xác xác thông tiên tục chỉ đạo lúc lượng kẻ xác xác thông tàn của xích sẽ còn lý cấp phép xe yêu tiên.
Sự liết với với pháp của xe kêu thương.
Lãm giúp bật phát tiền hiệu tiên tự tiện.
Đi đau cũng bật tiền hiệu tiên.
Khen cứ thù hồi xe phép đời với xe kêu thương vi pháp.